what are your expectations out of cop 26
what do you want to see
at the end of the two weeks here
i want us to come out with an agreement
that keeps 1.5 in reach it's absolutely
the line for us if we go past it the
future is really quite unimaginable i
want to see that we have support
and solidarity on particularly
adaptation issues for my country
living with 1.1 is a challenge living
with 1.5 is going to be very painful and
we're going to need to adapt in
transformative ways and we're going to
need
support to do that and so we really need
to see in addition finance there's got
to be resources for the most vulnerable
to do what needs to be done to stay
a part of this global community
when you say support and you're talking
essentially now about money
the rich countries had promised to put
together a fund of i think 100 billion
dollars um
it's not entirely clear how far they got
with this but it doesn't sound like
they've even got into double figures yet
does that
inspire much trust in you that they're
taking this seriously i'll be really
frank it's it's it's a huge
disappointment it's
it's very difficult uh when you're told
that um
resources are putting and are being put
in place and and to not to not see that
happen
there has been a a plan delivered and
there's been a lot of work done to say
how we will get there
and we're going to continue working with
our partners to make sure that that in
fact happens but we also need to think
beyond
2025 what is going to be the finance
goal beyond that and those talks start
at this cop and we need all of our
partners to to support us to ensure that
we're going to address this problem at
the scale
that is required
the you said earlier on this month that
you thought the key to progress actually
lay not
here but in the g20
are you hearing anything from rome that
gives you any encouragement
we've done as much as we can do to try
to
send the message
alongside some of our partners my
president signed a letter alongside
the prime minister of denmark and
ireland's leader and several others to
really send the message to the g20 that
look
the major emitters this group you have
the key you can keep 1.5 in sight
if you just put in those concrete
policies and actions that we all need
now in this critical decade
and
i am still waiting to see what's coming
out of that meeting i've heard both
some positive and and some really
challenging things i think we know that
this is going to be a very tough two
weeks
and
i just can't let up hope because failure
is really not an option for my country
what um
bring it to life for us what would be
the consequences for your country
if that 1.5
degree target isn't met i have to tell
you
beyond 1.5 is unimaginable for for my
country we are um an atoll nation that
sits just two meters above sea level
i don't know if what if you know what
that means um two meters is
it's a it's an a nation of coastline
we don't even have hills trevor so
um we're looking at sea level rise of
0.5 meters um at 1.5
and
as you said that means inundations
yearly inundations we need to start
thinking about how to raise land
buildings how are we going to survive in
that 1.5 world so beyond 1.5 we cannot
go
so
the situation you're describing in a way
suggests that um
if we don't fix this
in 50 years time what we now call the
marshall islands as a state will be
history
i can't accept that outcome that that's
not acceptable to me and i don't think
it should be acceptable to any
person or nation in this world to write
off a country
and what i keep telling
partners is
we're on the front lines we're on the
front of the front lines we are the most
vulnerable
but if you protect the most vulnerable
you protect yourself and you protect
your children
and i think we've really learned if
anything from covid
if you protect the front line everyone
is protected
we were speaking briefly before and uh i
was saying my family comes from
guyana which is um
not entirely below sea level but the the
most
densely inhabited parts of the country
lie 20 feet below school
below sea level and i'm thinking as
you're speaking that actually
if it were not for the sea wall um the
school that i went to
would actually be under water
is it do you think that there is
actually
realistically the possibility of
protecting countries like this or is it
just now too late
it can't be too late and we're working
on a national adaptation plan which we
call our survival plan
and
we have to have hope for our future i'm
not consigning
our future to history that's not a
choice
our choice is to work and to fight to
make sure
that we have
safety and security for my children and
for my children's children
that's going to be a different reality
it's going to be a transformed reality
we see that
but we don't accept that reality means
no future
what are you saying to alex sharma
that
success will look like for you in two
weeks time what what concretely do you
want to see him delivering uh in two
weeks time
we need the cop presidency's top
president to start us out with very high
ambition at this cop we need to have
processes that
make sure
we understand there is a gap how are we
meeting that gap
there
we're not going to make 1.5 if we're not
going to make it at this cop how can we
keep it on the table that has to be our
guiding star in addition we need to
understand what are we going to do to
make sure that we're looking at
adaptation how are we going to help
those the most vulnerable like my
country to actually live in this present
that that we're looking at now and we
also need to see the resources that
you know we're going to have the finance
to be able to adapt and
secure our future